[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on
Linda hi thank you so much for taking my
call happy to do so what's going
on so my parents are retired and they're
in the process of getting
divorced um my mom is going to be
keeping the house but she won't have
very much to live on so my siblings and
I um are thinking of taking on the
mortgage and my question is does it make
sense for us to take on the mortgage for
this house that's older and it needs
significant Renovations or should we try
to sell and find my mom a new place to
live I'm going for option number two
because it's way
cleaner I'm just IM like when you
started talking about that my brain
started imagining all the ways that can
go south because how many siblings is
it um there's three of us will be able
to take on that responsibility so let's
just pretend you guys split the mortgage
equally and then suddenly one sibling
falls on hard times or something happens
in their world and they're not able to
hold up their end of the bargain and so
now it's falls on two siblings and then
God forbid something happens and another
sibling goes through something with
their life and their family and they
realize hey this is not a priority do
you see how that can kind of unravel
very
quickly yeah definitely that that what
we've been thinking though is even if we
try to buy something new we'll still all
have to pitch in um so it's kind of what
is her retirement income three ways yeah
uh it's not much um so with social
security um my mom will have about
2800 that's something it's just her and
yeah she can't afford an apartment that
is sorry she can't afford a condo or an
apartment
not in New York does she have to live in
do all the siblings live in the White
Plains
area yeah we pretty much all live in the
same area we consider relocating but
like for the entire family to relocate
that that would be significant is there
any spousal support what's going to
happen what's how's the dust going to
settle from this divorce as far as the
finances
go yeah so pretty much splitting my
dad's pension in half um but he has more
Social Security because he was the one
working so he'll be able to live on what
what he gets but my mom won't quite be
able to make ends meet so she'll have
the 2800 plus half of his
pension no that is that's including that
includes the pension okay so if you were
to sell the house what would it
bring um in the condition that is
now maybe 100
150,000 it would only go for 15 50
Grand because it lot of renovation then
I think we need to get her out of there
anyways what's going to happen when you
take on a big mortgage and you have to
pay for all these Renovations and none
of you even live
there yeah well um you know we're all in
our 30s we've all been saving for our
own homes so what we're thinking is
we'll just keep renting and and use
those so you're going to delay the rest
of your financial future to keep mom
living this dream SL
nightmare I would sell it and I'd get
her a real uh you know real just quaint
little condo in apartment and if that
can get her mortgage lower to where she
can still afford it and that's great but
I would not refinance this thing and you
guys take on the loan but her name's on
the title no it's going to implode the
family sooner rather than later what's
your net
worth um my net worth is about uh it's
probably about
150,000 yeah and if you had to guess
your siblings where are they sitting at
if you had to
guess oh somewhat less than that I don't
know what their net worth is but they
make about 60,000 a year and they
probably have they probably have that
average debt that sort of thing I'd
rather mom go live with one siblings at
this point all could she live with one
of
y'all um yeah yeah that's definitely
possible it's it's just hard for us to
think of you know our mom having to move
back into an apartment she loves being
outdoors she loves gardening she has two
big dogs she can still go outside and
she can still like there's so much that
she can still do I think you guys have
to grieve what's taken place and grieve
the fact that you guys all had this
ideal picture of what your mom would be
doing at this age and what that would
look like and that it's not like that
everything can I also just say she
doesn't get to have her dreams when she
did nothing to prepare for those
dreams that's a hard thing to say out
loud cuz I'm sure she's a Wonder ful
person an amazing mother but she's
sitting here with a mortgage no
retirement and hoping to live off of
Social
Security and so we have to also face
reality as John deloney would say one of
his daily decisions we have to make is
choose reality and the reality is she
can't afford the life that she wants and
you guys are going to prop it up while
setting back your own Financial Futures
which is only going to build a
resentment it only takes one of these
Jenga blocks to fall one of the siblings
to go this sucks I'm out to where
everyone hates each
other yeah I think here I liked G I
liked George's idea of possibly her
living with you guys for a while here's
what I'm thinking and you can poke holes
in this if you sell this house um and
you get 150 out of it I'm get now when I
asked you what would it bring I wanted
to know like what would you profit from
it not what so 150 is what you would
profit from it if I were you guys I'd
set that money aside and let it grow for
her and if you guys can work out a
situation where it's like Mom is living
with sibling one for a while and then
she's living with sibling 2 and maybe
over time you guys are able to figure
out a situation where she gets a little
apartment because she can draw some
money off of her nest egg and then she's
got the 2800 coming in and then she's
kind of sustainable on her own but I
would rather you guys work out a
situation on the front end that doesn't
involve you guys each ponying up a bunch
of cash you know and this long-term
thing of we're paying her rent or we're
paying her mortgage I just think that
that's going to drain all of
you yeah yeah that that that sounds good
I mean there will definitely we will
still have to contribute to her because
again with that income that she'll have
she won't be able to rent but like on
her own
um but yeah that's definitely I would
also do some homework and see what all
of the options are I know white Plaines
is expensive MH but I would be shocked
if there was wasn't a one bedroom for
$2,000
$2,300 and maybe you chip in to help
cover some of her groceries
mhm but we don't know how long we're
going to have to prop her lifestyle up
for I know that's right or maybe you
know maybe there's maybe there's a
friend or a somebody else where she can
get a roommate situation and they have a
Golden Girls deal going on and they're
just you know they find a way you know
they've got a companion they're having
fun and they're living in their
apartment life together either way the
vision that they had for their mom is
going to have to change and that's tough
I hate to have to tell them that but
yeah option A and B aren't great let's
look at CDE e f and then make a decision
as a family and I bet the further out
they go there's going to be something
cheaper they've just got to look for it
this is the Ramsey Show